[Música]
quisiera comenzar esta presentación con
una pregunta una pregunta un poco obvia
pero necesaria
porque tenemos universidades porque
tenemos todas estas estructuras tan
costosas una respuesta obvia a eso es
para aprender ahora que aprendemos en
una universidad
esto tiene miles infinitas posibilidades
de respuestas y detalles
la universidad esencialmente surge la
primera universidad reconocida y todavía
funcionando desde sus inicios la
universidad de bolonia 1088 en italia
surge como una
empresa como una institución que da
básicamente licencias para trabajar para
ser profesionales
y todas las personas que pasan por una
universidad se benefician enormemente de
este paso por la universidad consiguen
mejores niveles de vida salud calidad de
sociedad edad ingresos mejores esa es
una de las funciones básicas de la
universidad pero yo otra función muy
importante que la universidad tiene y
que está muy desarrollado últimamente
hace unos años viene es la universidad
que cuida mantiene y desarrolla
investigación crea conocimiento innova y
esto tiene un gran impacto en obviamente
la economía y la generación de trabajo
esto es las universidades son realmente
máquinas de generar empleo y generar
innovación en combinación con empresas y
diferentes instituciones
y eso es por un lado ahora la
universidad viene también experimentando
una serie de cuestionamientos de sus
funciones
muy fuertes en estos últimos años hacia
un movimiento de inclusión de la
sociedad dentro de la universidad lo que
se llama de engage y university en el
contexto anglosajón la universidad está
orientada a traerlas la realidad social
dentro de la universidad trabajar con
los factores sociales para transferir y
enseñar mejor y entendiendo que esto no
se soluciona solamente del lado de la
universidad
ahora quiero comentarles una quiero
comentarles una contarles una historia
una vez yo viajando desde europa cuando
vivíamos en europa por estudio y en un
viaje hacia canadá por un congreso en
uno en mil hilera de asiento había una
señora dos bancos más más allá nos
pusimos la resulta que esta profesora
era una producción la universidad de
universidad de pennsylvania state penn
state y ella y asia estaba en el ámbito
de biología y asia trans en intercambios
de los alumnos sobre más para aprender
me jugó oriente del mejor cómo
funcionaban los sistemas biológicos
naturales de esa los animales las
plantas mandaban estos los chicos
diferentes lugares especialmente donde
vías selvas tropicales como en costa
rica y entonces me cuenta la historia de
una alumna
vamos a llamar a andrea andrea fue
estuvo seis años seis meses en costa
rica y cuando volvió después de un
tiempo fue y le llamó la tocó las
puertas de las oficinas de esta persona
y de ahí se puede hablar con ustedes se
dice siente siéntate vamos a hablar y
entonces la alumna le contó todas sus
experiencias en costa rica forma
interesante pero también le contó que al
llegar a eeuu tuvo una serie de
experiencias únicas
y ésta hasta casi jugosa fuera
el walkman una tienda gigantesca y
cuando entro wolman sintió como que
había un shock algo la impacto qué fue
lo que el impacto realmente al entrar a
agua más por el impacto la abundancia la
cantidad de objetos que había allí la
superaba en abundancia le impactó ver
tanta abundancia y tanto derroche que no
sabía cómo procesar toda esta
información es decir la experiencia de
haber ido vivido en una comunidad rural
muy primitiva diríamos hoy comenzó a
recategorizar los valores de esta alumna
llamada andrea
y entonces
la universidad y una de las tendencias
fuertes que se están dando es que las
universidades comienzan a exponer a los
alumnos en tiempo real a comunidades a
experiencias para que entiendan lo que
está sucediendo en la vida práctica pero
no solamente para contribuir como una
bondad sino como para traer las
comunidades y ser socias juntas para
generar conocimiento y aplicación
ahora
con lluvia jugando por algunas
universidades y diferentes lugares
observó que en general el modelo
universitario que impera en todo el
mundo
es un modelo básicamente materialista o
sea es entrenar a la persona darle una
serie de habilidades ayudarlo
desarrollar habilidades para un trabajo
para que tenga impacto social económico
y una mejor y justa sociedad y todo esto
en el fondo está muy bien nadie está
cuestionado al ver esto ahora quiero
traerles a la tensión
parece que eso no es suficiente para el
éxito de un alumno y el éxito de una
sociedad miren les voy a mostrar vamos a
ver aquí por favor daniel pásame las
placas a uno y les voy a mostrar lo que
está pasando en este momento en eeuu lo
que ha venido pasando nuestro
especialmente estos últimos 20 años
este es el total de suicidios en el
incremento de suicidios en eeuu como
ustedes pueden ver especialmente los
varones son más efectivos de suicidarse
ha habido un incremento especialmente de
los años 2000 en adelante drástico y
muchos jóvenes adolescentes y
universitarios están a la cabeza de
estos procesos si vemos la placa número
podemos ver podemos observar como ha ido
incrementando el más rojo significa más
intensidad más casos de shu zhi
en anuales esto es el porcentaje sobre
las
cifras normales todos los estados tienen
cierta cantidad de suicidios pero en los
últimos 15-20 años
este esto sin estos niveles de intentos
de suicidios han crecido drásticamente
en algunos casos más del 50%
vamos a la siguiente placa que es esta
esta retirada de la american foundation
su site pretensión es una de las más
autoridad en términos de suicidios
alrededor de en este momento en eeuu de
las diez mayores causas de muerte una de
ese suicidio es hace dos años murieron
alrededor de 48 mil personas hubo en el
2017 1 millón 400 mil intentos de
suicidio no sabemos cuántas personas
tuve ver más intentos por personas esto
cuesta miles de millones de dólares en
el sistema médico y demás porque una
persona no es el objetivo de esta de
esta charla porque las personas se
quieren suicidar pero definidamente es
un problema que se da y como explicamos
qué sucede en una sociedad que tiene
todo lo que podríamos decir que
humanamente hablando
buena salud buena educación niveles de
su sociedad estable mucho trabajo mucho
futuro y parece no alcanzar fíjense
interesante este fenómeno no es
solamente de países desarrollados luego
presentó en la placa número 4 este es el
caso particular solamente lo tome como
un ejemplo nada más de córdoba
córdoba desde el 2005 al 2015 ha
manifestado ha habido un incremento de
200 57% de intentos de suicidios
es alarmante o sea por qué pasa esto
[Música]
a mí me parece que
hay razones hay muchas razones pero una
de las razones más importantes el
incremento casi exponencial también de
acuerdo a diferentes estudios de la
cantidad del individualismo del
consumismo que se está dando en la
sociedad hoy en día del aislamiento
social que se da antes de la pandemia
hablemos
un creciente aislamiento un creciente
centrarse en sí mismo
y alejarse de los propósitos de un
sentido de vida más grande y entonces es
allí donde realmente el desafío el
desafío es grande ahora qué función
podemos hablar de cuál es la alternativa
a esta problemática desde el punto de
vista universitario y yo quisiera
brevemente leerles un par de citas de
dos autores que han investigado el tema
en eeuu y esto se aplica perfectamente a
todo el mundo y representan voces de
cuestionamientos profundos de los
modelos en materialistas que y netamente
de consumismo que imperan en la
universidad y vamos a la placa número 5
este estos dos autores dicen gran parte
de la educación superior ha llegado a
operar en una especie de programa
predeterminado de individualismo
instrumental
esta es la noción familiar de que la
universidad existe para investigar y
difundir conocimientos y habilidad tales
como herramienta para el desarrollo
económico y la movilidad descendente de
las personas o sea nos centramos
esencialmente en la en lo material en el
empleo en buenas condiciones sociales
pero las personas cuando llegan a esos
niveles fallan comienza a fallar y
comienza a ver un incremento muy grande
de estas variables que estábamos
presentando ahora fíjense la última la
última placa que quiero compartir con
ustedes al número 6
también hace referencia al propósito de
la universidad
es la universidad no sé vamos a ver la
placa número 67 última este autor dice
no importa cuánta investigación
investigación brillante generemos
cuántos libros galardonados publiquemos
y cuántas personas se servimos a través
de actividades de divulgación nuestra
misión principal es la educación de los
estudiantes necesitamos continuar
encontrando nuevas estrategias para
mejorar el éxito de la nada de los
estudiantes y es aquí donde yo quiero
brindar una sugerencia nuevas
oportunidades para darle más éxito los
estudiantes
y yo creo que la universidad necesita y
esto es una tendencia que en cierto modo
se ve pero de manera esporádica y
distribuida de manera irregular crear
espacios académicos espacios
curriculares o curriculares más
definidos para contestar preguntas
[Música]
que hace referencia a las necesidades
más íntimas del ser humano
no alcanza con tener un buen ingreso no
alcanza con tener una profesión no
alcanza con contribuir socialmente aún
cuando yo hago buenas contribuciones
necesito contestar y buscar respuestas
orientación a mi a mi futuro personal
grupal también o sea las universidades
deberían y esta es una oportunidad
también para existir diferenciarse de
otras instituciones deberían incorporar
espacios
para justamente discutir estos estos
problemas que profesión vas a tomar qué
o qué vas a hacer con tu dinero cuál va
a ser tu contribución de vida tuvo un
legado como eliges incluso una cosa que
parece banal pero muy importante con
eliges tu pareja como eliges dónde vivir
que cómo gastas tu dinero cómo cuidas tu
cuerpo son todos elementos que yo los
llamaría la
la preparación de sus alumnos para
hacerlos más sabios y la sabiduría es un
elemento que parece netamente religioso
pero no hay verdad en este religioso
claro que tiene componentes religiosas
si se quiere que la sabiduría
esencialmente de acuerdo a varios
autores es la capacidad de distinguir
personalmente y grupalmente acciones que
me beneficien como persona y que
beneficien a un grupo de personas un
sector mayor o sea la persona sabes
aquella que sabe navegar las tensiones y
las necesidades personales y grupales
por el bien tanto de él como de la
sociedad en la que está esto se aprende
esto no se puede simplemente dejarlo al
azar
quiero contarles la historia de
alfred nobel todo de los de los famosos
premios nobel resulta que cuando no le
creo a la dinamita fue una revolución
industrial de química de la química
industrial muy positiva de hecho él se
hizo rico con
las minas y la capacidad de levantar
piedras a través de la dinamita
pero una de las cosas que lo llevo a
donar parte de su fortuna fue ver y con
mucho pesar que su invención al poco
tiempo se usó para destruir bancos robar
y matar
o sea el conocimiento per se no alcanza
algo parecido le sucedió a einstein
se cuenta la historia de que él se
entristeció mucho al ver el uso de la
energía nuclear de su conocimiento de
física nuclear para destruir y matar
o sea el el conocimiento per se no
alcanza que hace falta hace falta una
reconversión de la persona a la persona
necesita pensar sus propósitos y las
universidades podrían poner estos
espacios para ayudar a los alumnos a
pensar y hacer categorizar su futuro
ahora quiero destacar destacar como
punto final que en la mayoría de las
universidades la fe es totalmente
relegada
el repensar una posición de vida desde
una tradición de fe expuesta como algo
irrelevante casi como medieval
cuando estudios están diciendo que las
personas que practican y que tienen una
fe viva tienen mejores propósitos de
vida son más felices y contribuyen más a
la sociedad
claro hablemos de personas que viven una
fe genuina no hablemos de alguien que
vive una fe impuesta
y me parece que estos espacios
curriculares también tienen que abrir
las puertas a invitados para compartir
para entender para
y explorar
la necesidad espiritual
no alcanza con lo material el ser humano
es más que materia y esto es una
concepción antropológica que se expresa
a través de todos estas funciones que la
universidad tiene de entrenar de
producir conocimientos y de servicios
pero el usuario de todos esos elementos
es el ser humano soy yo y yo necesito
y dirigirme hacia el ser humano y
entrenarlo como un buen usuario entonces
me parece que
la universidad del siglo 21 necesitará
repensar sus funciones
en base a el ser humano y no solamente
la economía o el beneficio económico de
un grupo necesitamos repensar esto y
traducirlo en estructuras porque de otra
manera tenemos estas tendencias
negativas que están afectando
poderosamente a nuestros jóvenes y el
futuro de la sociedad
esa es la invitación y esa es la
reflexión para ahora
la universidad necesita ampliar expandir
su comprensión de ser humano
el ser humano no es solamente materia
y termino con una charla que tuve con un
profesor en alemania
le dije me dijo una vez porque sabe que
yo tengo una visión diferente de este
tema yo cuando llegue a europa
creí que que la fe era el mal de todas
las grandes guerras hasta que vi el
relativismo rampante y la falta de
estándares estándares de vida total me
di cuenta que
hay algo más aunque yo no creo en nada
pero algo más en el ser humano y este es
el desafío descubrirlo y explorarlo
porque puede ser que allí esté o puede
ser no para mí personalmente allí está
la fuente de felicidad que hace que el
ser humano se torne hacia los demás con
un propósito no necesariamente
humanística humanista un propósito
superior
muchas gracias por este momento de
reflexión y espero que sigamos
conversando
[Música]